the highly anticipated movie Wonder
Woman hits theaters next week the month
of May is the traditional start of
summer box office releases Wonder Woman
will compete for the big bucks against
movies like Baywatch and the latest
Pirates of the Caribbean which both
opened today Christa Smith is West Coast
editor of Vanity Fair and a CBS News
contributor good morning Christopher
morning so Wonder Woman you'll have
Charlize Theron in atomic blonde is
finally the moment we've been waiting
for the reel action blockbuster I really
hope so I mean I think it's great that
Wonder Woman it's obviously a title we
all know about there was a TV show and
70s there's a lot riding on it it looks
really fun she's great out the dog
obviously knows what she's doing now she
was in the Israeli army any time so she
is for real it's got a female director
Pattie and Hattie Jenkins and a great
cast so I think it'll do gangbusters
it's a big there's a lot riding on it
right a lot riding on it and also on the
flip side of that there's this movie
called atomic blonde which they sneaked
at the South by Southwest Film Festival
that's excellent that star Charlize
Theron and kind of like a female born
right at the end of the Cold War and
what she does with shoulder pads and
high heels is fabulous well most women
do shoulder pads in high heels it's
fabulous Nicole Kidman was both them did
it coming out yeah she's amazing she's
as they say having a kid mana sauce or
whatever she was great in a big
obviously with big little lies that HBO
series and she is in the remake Sofia
Coppola is remake of beguiled though
from the Clint Eastwood movie of the 70s
and that's got a great cast another
female director Kirsten Dunst Elle
Fanning a lot a lot of anticipation is
that one the summer blockbuster season
is not usually Oscar bait and yet you're
optimistic about Kathryn Bigelow's
Detroit and Christopher Nolan of Batman
Fame his movie Dunkirk
right I you have Christopher Nolan
Dunkirk very famous battle World War two
that movie I feel could go all the way
through award season the same with
Kathryn Bigelow Detroit about the riots
in 1967 you have these both of them are
formidable do
directors taking on FIGS real life story
so I very accidentally because a lot of
people know the name Dunkirk but don't
know exact Lisa rounded trap 400,000
soldiers of the Allied soldiers trapped
and how they got them out and how
actually it was the civilians that that
every year are we of realizing the fact
that Hollywood's recognize the potential
of female directors as well as female
lead stars in movies that can carry and
do well at the box office
inch by inch it's by its lonely very
very I mean we also still have the
juggernauts of Tom Cruise and rummy
Johnny Depp is right pyrophoric a
premiere we've been talking about these
movie stars for two decades there's not
going to be like that in the
unemployment line in Hollywood but
nonetheless we're optimistic Kristen
Smith thanks for your time good great to
you and tomorrow on CBS this morning
Saturday a conversation with Wonder
Woman patty Jaffa would ruin director
the cookie patty Jenkins who is her
Wonder Woman in her room right the
superhero saga is the first comic book
movie in Hollywood history to be
directed by a woman that is tomorrow